From the WBEZ Chicago, it's Your Radio Playhouse.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这里是“您的广播剧场”。
Hi. My name is Reverend Calvin Bridges. And I'm the minister of music of at the Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church. And the music that you will hear tonight is being provided by the Faith Tabernacle Voices and the Faith Tabernacle Youth Voices.
大家好。我叫卡尔文·布里奇斯牧师。我是信仰会幕浸信会教堂的音乐牧师。今晚你们将听到的音乐由信仰会幕之声和信仰会幕青年之声共同献上。
[CHOIR SINGING]
[唱诗班合唱]
Your Radio Playhouse . Well, it's a special treat tonight to bring you music, over the course of the hour, from the Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church down at 82nd and Stony on Chicago's South Side. Our thinking was that by this point in the Christmas season, people are pretty much tired of the regular Christmas records. So we thought that we would bring different music.
您的广播剧场。今晚我们为您带来一小时的特别节目，音乐来自位于芝加哥南区第82街和斯托尼大道的信仰会幕浸信会教堂。我们的想法是，到了圣诞节这个阶段，人们对常规的圣诞唱片已经感到厌倦了。所以我们想带来一些不一样的音乐。
I'm Ira Glass. Also this evening, we have amazing new stories by Reginald Gibbons, and Beau O'Reilly, and others. We have the debut of a new radio theater company. How often do you really get to say those words in 1990? A new radio theater company created by writer David Sedaris, his sister Amy, a bunch of other people. They call themselves the Pine Tree Gang.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天晚上，我们还有雷金纳德·吉本斯、博·奥莱利等人创作的精彩新故事。我们还要介绍一个新广播剧团的首演。在1990年，你们能听到多少次这样的开场白呢？这是一个由作家大卫·塞达里斯、他的妹妹艾米以及其他几个人共同创立的广播剧团。他们自称“松树帮”。
You know, the thing about Christmas is, that a Christmas, people are like themselves but more so. You know the saying that you can tell a lot about a person in a crisis? You can tell a lot about a person at Christmas also. That is not because Christmas is a crisis. As one of the producers on this program, Nancy Updike, has suggested this week, it's because Christmas is the one day in the American year when, more than any other, we are, all of us, handed exactly the same stage props with which to manufacture a day. The same expectations, the same presents, the same tree, the same idea of the meal, all that is handed to all of us. And everybody is trying to fashion a day out of exactly the same materials. And when people do that, you could see exactly who chooses, what they choose, and why. At Christmas, the kind hearted have an event on which they can exercise their kind heartedness. The impatient have more reason to be impatient. The manipulative and controlling have a set of meals and gifts with which to manipulate others. Everybody is themselves but more so.
你知道，关于圣诞节的一点是，在圣诞节，人们还是原来的自己，但表现得更为极致。你知道那句老话吗，一个人在危机时刻的表现能说明很多问题？其实在圣诞节也是如此。这并不是因为圣诞节是一场危机。正如本节目的一位制作人南希·厄普代克本周所言，这是因为圣诞节是美国一年中，所有人比在任何时候都被赋予完全相同的“舞台道具”来过节的一天。同样的期望，同样的礼物，同样的圣诞树，同样的聚餐概念，这一切都被分发给所有人。每个人都在试图用完全相同的材料来过好这一天。当人们这样做时，你就能清楚地看到谁选择了什么，以及为什么要这样选择。在圣诞节，心地善良的人有一个可以施展爱心的场合。急躁的人有更多理由变得急躁。爱操纵和控制他人的人有一套聚餐和礼物来支配他人。每个人都是他们自己，但表现得更为极致。
Which brings us to our radio play. Writer David Sedaris had an odd experience in his life. Namely, one of the first, big, public things that he did in his life is, he went on to National Public Radio and told the story of how he had worked as an elf at Santa Land at Macy's Department Store for two Christmases.
这就引出了我们的广播剧。作家大卫·塞达里斯生活中曾有过一次奇特的经历。那就是，他人生中第一次重大的公开活动，就是登上国家公共广播电台，讲述他在梅西百货的圣诞乐园当了两个圣诞节精灵的故事。
And pretty much for the course of the two years which followed, every Christmas he would get lots of calls from magazines, and newspapers, and TV, and radio. People who wanted to hear yet another Christmas story, wanted him to unfold another Christmas story, bring one out. Here's the Christmas guy. You know, here's the Christmas guy. And these requests, they inundated him and confounded him. No one wants to be considered, for the rest of their life, as an elf. And so I think that was part of the inspiration for his radio play this evening. A premier radio play of our new radio group here at Your Radio Playhouse . The Pinetree Gang.
在那之后的两年里，每个圣诞节他都会接到大量杂志、报纸、电视和广播电台的电话。人们想听另一个圣诞故事，想让他再讲一个圣诞故事出来。这儿有“圣诞先生”。你知道，这儿有位“圣诞先生”。这些请求让他感到不知所措，也让他倍感困扰。没有人愿意余生都被视为一个“精灵”。所以我认为这也是他今晚这部广播剧的灵感来源之一。这是我们“您的广播剧场”新广播剧团的首部广播剧——松树帮。
Last Christmas I decided to splurge and treat myself to a really extravagant present, something I'd always wanted, myself. Not who I wish I was, or what others wanted me to be. No. Just plain old me. No fancy extras, no cash return, no exchange, just myself, Gene Larkin, wrapped up in a bright, brown ribbon of self acceptance. Take it or leave it. Leaving it, saying, no to myself was a pattern as old as the checkerboard plaid I used to cover my windows. I decided to break my old pattern and set fire to my curtains, allowing both myself and others to start dealing with the real me. The me who asks, who says you can't drive to work in a go kart when you feel like it? The me who says, let's start cooking with grapes for a change.
去年圣诞节，我决定挥霍一下，给自己买了一份真正奢华的礼物，一份我一直想要的东西。不是别人希望我成为的样子，也不是别人想要我成为的样子。不。就是单纯的我。没有花哨的额外赠品，不能退款，不能退换，只有我自己，吉恩·拉金，包裹在一条明亮的棕色自尊自爱的丝带里。你要也好，不要也罢。以前，我总是对自己说“不”，这就像我用来遮住窗户的格子窗帘一样，是一个陈旧的模式。我决定打破这个旧模式，把窗帘烧掉，让自己和别人都开始面对真实的我。那个会问，谁说你想开卡丁车去上班就不能开的？那个会说，我们要不要换换口味，改用葡萄做菜的我。
I went through my life, removing all the barricades that said, no, you can't do that. Because me, I can do anything I want. One of the things I can do is type. And another is to think about myself and my needs. I just never had the time or the opportunity to really knuckle down and practice my craft. After they had fired me for parking my go kart in the boss's handicapped space, I found myself with a lot of extra time on my hands. And the opportunity, it came by way of the Center for Annex Learning, a former indoor skating facility the city fathers have turned into what they call a school without walls.
我走过我的人生，拆除了所有写着“不，你不能那样做”的栅栏。因为我，我可以做任何我想做的事。我可以做的事情之一就是打字。另一件事是思考我自己和我的需求。我只是从来没有时间和机会真正静下心来练习我的技艺。在我因为把卡丁车停在老板的残疾人车位而被解雇后，我发现自己空出了很多时间。而机会通过“安内克斯学习中心”到来，这是一个被市政府改造成所谓的“无墙学校”的室内滑冰场。
The classrooms are separated by curtains, but that's just for the sake of privacy. The real walls are in our minds. And the center is devoted to helping us tear them down brick by brick. I can't stand walls, not anymore. You should see what I've done with my house. I'm still working on it. But in the meantime, I dropped by the Center and signed up for a course called, "Writing for the Holidays." Because, as the teacher said,
教室之间用窗帘隔开，但这只是为了隐私。真正的墙在我们的脑海里。而该中心致力于帮助我们一块砖一块砖地拆除这些墙。我受不了墙，再也受不了了。你应该看看我对我的房子做了什么。我还在努力改造它。但在此期间，我去了中心，报了一门课叫“假期写作”。因为，正如老师所说，
Chances are, if you've got a story to tell, you've got a story to sell. How many of you would like that [JINGLING BELLS] jingling sound to come from your pockets? Would you like that?
只要你有故事要讲，你就很可能有一个故事能卖出去。你们中有多少人希望口袋里发出那种[摇铃声]清脆的响声？想吗？
I sure would love it.
我当然很想。
Love it.
想。
If it sounds too good to be true, then think again. Picture all the magazines and newspapers in this country lying side by side on a football field. That's a lot, right? And every single one of them is searching for a Christmas story to run in that all-important holiday issue. Even the radio and TV are looking for things like that. Newsletters, websites, town criers, you name it. It's a way of making yourself some real money. A thought that united everyone in the class.
如果这听起来好得令人难以置信，那就再想想。想象一下这个国家所有的杂志和报纸并排铺在足球场上。那很多，对吧？它们每一家都在寻找一个圣诞故事来刊登在那个极其重要的节日刊号上。甚至广播和电视也在寻找这样的内容。通讯、网站、城镇公告员，凡你能想到的。这是一种让自己真正赚到钱的方式。这个想法让班上的每个人都团结了起来。
How much money are we talking about? Can I get an advance? I want some boots.
我们要赚多少钱？能预付稿费吗？我想买双靴子。
Can the money be spent on lodging?
钱可以用来支付住宿费吗？
The money can be spent on anything you want, lodging, boots, gas, even stamps.
钱可以花在任何你想花的地方，住宿、靴子、汽油，甚至是邮票。
What about drink and games of chance?
那酒水和博彩呢？
That too. But first, you've got to sell your story. Which means you'll have to know your audience.
也可以。但首先，你得把你的故事卖出去。这意味着你必须了解你的读者。
[GRUMBLING AND COMPLAINING SOUNDS]
[抱怨和不满的声音]
People, listen, listen. If you spent last Christmas, I don't know, coaching midget league basketball or designing a patio, chances are, the editors over at Cat Fancy or Chocolatier aren't going to be too interested.
各位，听着，听着。如果你去年圣诞节都在忙着，我不知道，训练小联盟篮球或设计露台，那么《猫咪迷》或《巧克力商》的编辑们可能不会太感兴趣。
But can't you spend the holidays coaching midget league, and like cats, and chocolate? I do.
但不能既在假期训练小联盟，又喜欢猫和巧克力吗？我就喜欢。
No. Of course, you can do both. But, the chances are, your one line, I like cats, won't be enough for an editor who's audience is made up of people who more than like cats. For these people, the cat or the chocolate, needs to be the focus of the whole, holiday story.
不。当然，你可以两者兼顾。但是，很可能你那句“我喜欢猫”不足以打动编辑，因为他们的读者群是由比“喜欢猫”更进一步的人组成的。对于这些人来说，猫或巧克力需要成为整个节日故事的核心。
What if the magazine is for people who love not liking anything?
如果杂志是给那些“什么都不喜欢”的人看的呢？
Then give them my number right away.
那立刻把我的号码给他们。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
No, seriously, the question's a good one. This young person seems to know what the magazine wants, and that's the first step. If you want to be published, you have to find a magazine and really stake it out. Study it under a good, strong lamp. The fine print, even the advertisements will give you an indication of who these people are and how the editors try to reach them. Yes?
不，说真的，这个问题问得很好。这位年轻人似乎知道杂志想要什么，这是第一步。如果你想出版，你必须找到一份杂志并真正地深耕它。在明亮的灯光下研究它。细则，甚至广告都能让你看出这些人是谁，以及编辑们是如何试图触达他们的。有哪位有疑问吗？
I once made a strong lamp out of a coconut husk my mother's brother's cousin Colonel Jeremy Hackford found on the beach at Topsoil Island. The husk was tattered and sunburnt, resembling the head of one of grandmother's servants. A moon-faced child by the name of--
我曾经用我母亲的兄弟的表弟杰里米·哈克福德上校在表土岛海滩上发现的椰子壳做了一盏强力灯。那椰子壳又破又被晒焦了，看起来很像祖母的一个仆人的头。那个叫……的月亮脸孩子。
Great. So, I want each and every one of you to do that. Take a magazine and make it your own personal project. At the end of this course, I expect every single one of you to hold a contract in your hands. Let me rephrase that. If any of you don't want to publish a holiday story, I'm afraid I can't help you.
太棒了。所以，我希望你们每个人都这样做。拿一本杂志，把它作为你们个人的专项课题。课程结束时，我期望你们每个人手里都拿着一份合同。让我换个说法。如果你们当中有人不想出版节日故事，恐怕我帮不了你。
I'd really love to be published, especially around the holidays. I'd take that money, the paper clutched tight, like a prize, like a ticket. And I'd use it to fly, like a soft prayer-carpet. I'd mount it and work our magic out of here, out of the window, and over the stained quilt of this life, this town, where every stitch is a fence, a barrier, a landscape, embroidered with no. A land sewn, not to comfort, but to smother. I'd take that carpet--
我真的非常想出版，特别是在节日期间。我会拿着那笔钱，紧紧攥在手里，像个奖品，像张入场券。我会用它飞翔，像一块柔软的祈祷地毯。我会骑上它，带着我们的魔法离开这里，穿出窗户，飞过这沉重的人生、这个小镇那被打满补丁的被子。这里的每一道针脚都是一道栅栏，一道屏障，一片绣着“不”字的山水。这是一片被缝合的土地，不是为了慰藉，而是为了窒息。我会带着那块地毯——
What if you'd really like to be published, but certain people think that your dead and it's better off to keep it that way?
如果一个人真的想出版，但某些人认为你已经死了，而且最好保持这种状态呢？
What if someone found a stray kitten in the locker room while coaching midget league and eating chocolate? Can I send it to three magazines?
如果有人在训练小联盟时在更衣室里发现了一只流浪猫，同时还在吃巧克力呢？我可以把它发给三家杂志吗？
Is it all right to turn in a manuscript written in blood or semen?
用血或精液写的手稿可以投递吗？
Typed, double spaced, unless it's written for one of the many handwriting analysis or calligraphy magazines.
打印，双倍行距，除非是为众多笔迹分析或书法杂志撰写的。
Do 'zines count?
“粉丝杂志”算吗？
Is justifiable political manslaughter acceptable in a Christmas story?
圣诞故事里可以包含合理的政治性过失杀人吗？
It was a great class. Everyone was really into it. And the teacher, he had this way of firing us up and cracking the type of whip you knew wouldn't break the surface of your skin, no matter how close you got to the many barbed tips. Like a lot of us, I love to write but often have to wait for an office party or a rowdy Presbyterian funeral for the mood to hit me. The teacher though, he explained how those same feelings of jubilation or sorrow can be reproduced through drugs and alcohol or tossing a hard, cold body into a shallow grave.
那真是一门很棒的课。每个人都全身心投入。而那位老师，他有一种激发我们热情的方式，他挥舞的那种鞭子，你知道无论你离那些倒钩尖端多近，它都不会划破你的皮肤。像我们很多人一样，我喜欢写作，但通常不得不等到办公室派对或一场吵闹的长老会葬礼才能产生灵感。然而，老师解释了如何通过药物、酒精，或者把一具冰冷的尸体扔进浅坑里，来复制那种狂喜或悲伤的感受。
The grave part, it's like you reached in and pulled the thoughts out of my very heart.
关于坟墓那部分，感觉就像你直接伸手掏出了我内心深处的想法。
Or the whiff of a sneaker yanked off the foot of a husky 13-year-old with a sprained ankle and a 39-point game average?
或者是脱掉一个有着扭伤脚踝、场均得分39分的壮硕13岁少年的运动鞋时那一阵臭味？
[MURMURS OF DISAGREEMENT AND CONFUSION]
[嘈杂的反对和困惑声]
People, people, what I'm trying to say, is that we're all people.
各位，各位，我想说的是，我们都是人。
He was so smart that way, always reminding us that we were all people, always taking us that one step further.
他在这方面非常聪明，总是提醒我们大家都是人，总是带着我们更进一步。
All right people, you've got your magazines. Now, let's start thinking about the stories. Christmas people, what does that bring to mind. Yvonne?
好了各位，你们已经选好杂志了。现在，让我们开始构思故事吧。圣诞节的人，这让你想到了什么？伊冯娜？
Christmas. All right. Christmas, the holidays. A really small knapsack filled with nail polish. It's lying there on the futon. I see something. It's something corduroy crumbled up and next to the TV. And there's a hair brush, my hair brush, used to prop open the window. It's cold outside and raining. And I can hear my roommate crying in the next room.
圣诞节。好吧。圣诞节，假期。一个装满指甲油的小背包。它躺在榻榻米上。我看到一样东西。那是某种褶皱的灯芯绒放在电视机旁边。还有一个发刷，我的发刷，用来撑开窗户。外面很冷，还在下雨。我能听到隔壁房间里我的室友在哭。
[LAUGHTER]
[笑声]
So it's minus 12 degrees outside, and I'm at an out-of-town game coaching the Lady Diamondbacks. Can you believe it? You couldn't find a sweeter, more talented group of girls. And every one of them was 100% drug free. I made sure of that baby.
当时外面零下12度，我正在外地教练“戴蒙德巴克小姐队”。你能相信吗？你找不到比这群女孩更可爱、更有天赋的团队了。她们每个人都百分之百不碰违禁品。我保证这一点，宝贝。
She turned to me on last time saying, don't do it Jerry Maguire. You were born for better things. Drink up now son. It's Christmas time, and we've got an early morning's Mass tomorrow. [CHOKING BACK TEARS] That was the last time I saw her.
她最后一次转向我说，别做那傻事，杰里·麦奎尔。你生来就是做大事的人。喝吧，孩子。现在是圣诞节了，我们明天还有清晨的弥撒。[哽咽]那是我最后一次见到她。
I like that, corduroy and the Lady Diamondbacks. What else?
我喜欢那个，灯芯绒和戴蒙德巴克小姐队。还有别的吗？
The sky was cloudless, the color of a burnished silver platter on that day when daddy and I set out with our aging spaniel Curtis in search of, what we considered to be, the perfect Christmas tree. A magnificent--
天空晴朗无云，像一个抛光的银盘，那天我和爸爸带着我们上了年纪的西班牙猎犬柯蒂斯出发，去寻找我们认为完美的圣诞树。一棵壮丽的——
Conflict, good. Every story needs it. You can sit down now, sister.
冲突，很好。每个故事都需要冲突。你可以坐下了，姐妹。
The class started in early September, so as to allow us to finish our stories early enough to allow magazines, what they call, their lead-time. Back-breaking unions force these publishers to be ready weeks, sometimes months in advance. To us, Christmas falls somewhere towards the end of December. But to these editors, that holiday has already come and gone. They're working on Valentine's Day or President's Day, or even Saint Patrick's by that time. It was hard to think about the holidays when, technically, it was late summer, and people were still dressed in shorts and halter tops. But the teacher, he did his best to get us into the spirit.
课程从九月初开始，以便让我们能足够早地完成故事，给杂志留出他们所谓的“交稿周期”。繁重的工会要求这些出版商提前几周甚至几个月准备好内容。对我们来说，圣诞节发生在十二月底。但对于这些编辑来说，节日已经过去了。他们那时正在做情人节、总统日，甚至是圣帕特里克节的策划。当天气还是夏末，人们还穿着短裤和吊带背心时，要考虑节日真的很困难。但老师尽力让我们进入状态。
All right people, I've got this fragrant, eight foot spruce. What do you say, we trim it?
各位，我有一棵芳香的八英尺高的云杉。你们说，我们要装饰它吗？
Now, in the daylight?
现在，在大白天？
We can mask the window.
我们可以把窗户遮住。
Then how will I know when my nephew's come to pick me up? You know I have to leave early on Thursdays.
那我怎么知道我侄子什么时候来接我？你知道我周四必须早点走。
If you don't mind, I think I'll wait outside in the student pub. There's something about trees inside that makes me nervous.
如果你不介意的话，我想在学生酒吧外面等。树放在室内总让我感到紧张。
Don't ornaments carry a lot of baggage?
装饰品难道不带有太多的负担吗？
They might, they very well might. But I'm ready to face my demons. How about you?
也许会，很有可能。但我准备面对我的心魔了。你呢？
It wasn't easy or fun, but we did it. We did it to remind ourselves what we were writing about. Outside the building, the trees were green and leafy. But in this room, it was Christmas, even to the several Jews and heretics. A few people stepped outside to smoke or make phone calls. And in a way, I think they really missed out. Maybe they could just hold Christmas inside their heads by re-reading old catalogs or paying bills. But for most of us, these little exercises really helped. The teacher had us start each class with a carol.
这并不容易，也不有趣，但我们做到了。我们这样做是为了提醒自己我们在写些什么。大楼外，树木依然郁郁葱葱。但在教室里，已经是圣诞节了，即便是对那些犹太人和异教徒来说也是如此。有些人走出教室去抽烟或打电话。某种程度上，我觉得他们真的错过了。也许他们只能通过重读旧目录或付账单在脑海中保持圣诞氛围。但对于我们大多数人来说，这些练习真的很有帮助。老师让我们每节课都以颂歌开始。
[HUMMING  CHRISTMAS CAROLS]
[哼唱圣诞颂歌]
And we all shaved ice, wrapped empty boxes as gifts, and sent fake, funny checks to charities. One day, he even brought chestnuts into the class and roasted them, right there, on a small, charcoal grill.
我们都刮冰屑，把空盒子当作礼物包装起来，并向慈善机构寄去有趣的假支票。有一天，他甚至带了一些栗子到教室里，就在那个小木炭烤架上烤了起来。
[COUGHING, CHOKING]
[咳嗽、呛声]
He made a chart of what each magazine paid per word and read us a few examples of their previous holiday stories.
他做了一张图表，列出了每本杂志每字的稿费，并给我们读了几个他们以前节日故事的例子。
It was grueling work, but I did it. I'd received the doe late on Christmas Eve, and had her fully mounted by the next morning, just in time to make one little girl's dreams come true. That's "Doe for a Deer," from the December '94 issue of Mounted Game Monthly .
工作很艰苦，但我完成了。我在平安夜很晚才收到那头母鹿，到第二天早上就把它完全制成了标本，正好赶上让一个小女孩梦想成真。这就是刊登在94年12月《标本狩猎月刊》上的《母鹿的故事》。
That was very beautiful.
那太美了。
Yes, it was. So how many words did we have there, word count, people?
是的，确实很美。那么我们这里有多少字，数一下，各位？
He stretched the skin on a pallet.
他在托盘上拉伸了皮肤。
According to my calculations, and I got a little bit bleary at the sad parts, I'd say that that story clocked in at about 945 words.
根据我的计算，而且在悲伤的部分我还有点眼花，我觉得那个故事大约有945字。
All right. And this particular magazine pays how much per word?
好了。那么这本特定的杂志每字付多少钱？
$0.55 per word.
每字0.55美元。
So that amounts to what? That's $472 and some change for our friend, Mr. Carlton Burke, from mounted game monthly. Yes?
那总共是多少？我们这位来自《标本狩猎月刊》的朋友卡尔顿·伯克先生赚了472美元多一点。有疑问吗？
But this class cost me $600.
但这门课花了我600美元。
Hey, that's right.
嘿，你说得对。
This is a rip-off.
这简直是坑人。
You just can't win.
你就是赢不了。
The whole system is rigged. Isn't there a way this Carlton person could've made more money?
整个系统都是操纵好的。难道这个卡尔顿就不能赚更多钱吗？
Yes, there is. He could've sold it to a better magazine or padded it with adjectives and adverbs.
可以的。他可以把它卖给更好的杂志，或者用形容词和副词来充实它。
He went back through the story, demonstrating how the author might have made extra money by employing a more fragrant and descriptive vocabulary.
他回到故事中，演示了作者如何通过运用更生动、更具描述性的词汇来赚取额外收入。
Take this one word, needle. What else could he have called it? Yes?
拿这个词来说，针。他还可以称它为什么？哪位有想法？
A sharp, pin-like device used for piercing holiday fabric or the flesh of a doe shot and mounted in order to serve as a gift for the holidays?
一种尖锐的、类似针的装置，用于刺穿节日布料，或刺穿为节日礼物而射杀并制成标本的母鹿的皮肉？
That's terrific. See class, he's taken one word and stretched it into a 29 word sentence, with the added value of $19.95. And he's related it all to the holidays. Yes?
太棒了。大家看，他把一个词扩展成了一个29个字的句子，还额外赋予了19.95美元的价值。而且他把这一切都和节日联系在了一起。还有吗？
I remember, one time, the fields behind granddaddy's smoke house were flooded. And the starlings circled and quested, crisscrossing like so many fleeting--
我记得有一次，爷爷熏肉房后面的田地被淹了。椋鸟盘旋着，寻找着，像许多飞逝的——一样来回穿梭
What do you know. Listen people, we've only got three weeks left until Halloween. Let's do a little exercise. How many of you remember what it felt like to rise at 5:00 AM and shovel the driveway so that your visiting relatives would have a place to pitch their Christmas tent?
真有你的。听着，伙计们，离万圣节只剩三个星期了。我们做一个小练习。你们中有多少人记得清晨5点起床铲车道的感觉，只为了让来访的亲戚有个地方搭他们的圣诞帐篷？
I do. It was dark then. I had to use a lantern, and it smelled like gas.
我记得。那时天还没亮。我得用盏灯，而且闻起来有股煤气味。
Huh, the O'Shaughnessys on my mother's side, they thought they were all too good for tents. Talk about hard work. I'd be up at 3:00 in the morning, digging their lean-tos and huts out of the cold ground, without even gloves to project me.
哈，我母亲那边的奥肖内西一家，他们觉得住帐篷太掉价了。说起辛苦，我得在凌晨3点起床，从冰冷的地面里把他们的简易房和棚屋挖出来，连双手套都没有，也没人保护我。
Everything the teacher said opened a door or triggered a memory of some kind.
老师说的每一句话都打开了一扇门，或者触发了某种记忆。
How many of you have accidentally blinded a family member with a tree limb or an icicle?
你们中有多少人曾经不小心用树枝或冰柱弄伤过家人的眼睛？
I have.
我有过。
I'd forgotten all about that.
我差点都忘了这件事了。
Guilty as charged.
我也一样，有罪。
Talk about a Christmas.
这就是所谓的圣诞节啊。
Just a team member and a benched one.
只是一个队里的成员，还有一个在板凳上。
Remember people, you're all just types. Now, let's get out there and make some money.
记住各位，你们都只是类型。现在，出去赚点钱吧。
He never asked what we were working on, never assigned us any homework, or shared any of the holiday stories he had written. He lead by example and taught on the sheer strength of his character. Over the weeks, I came to think of him and the other students as family. They started getting on my nerves in little ways. But I couldn't hate them, because, as time passed, we grew to resemble one another, growing out our nails and wearing identical wind-breakers.
他从不问我们在做什么，从不布置家庭作业，也从不分享他写过的节日故事。他以身作则，凭借纯粹的人格力量进行教导。几周下来，我开始把他和其他学生当作家人。他们开始在一些小事上让我感到厌烦。但我无法讨厌他们，因为随着时间的推移，我们长得越来越像，留长了指甲，穿着一模一样的防风夹克。
The teacher noticed the change and discouraged us from talking about our stories, for fear of inciting the sort of jealousy that often results in bloodshed or small fires. On the last day of class, we each arrived carrying our completed holiday story, ready for submission, each including a stamped, self-addressed envelope. And then we celebrated with punch and carols, laughing and reminiscing until the sun set on that late October afternoon.
老师注意到了这种变化，并劝阻我们讨论彼此的故事，以免引发那种常导致流血或小规模火灾的嫉妒。在课程的最后一天，我们每个人都带着完成的节日故事来到这里，准备提交，每人都附上了一个贴好邮票的回邮信封。然后，我们喝着潘趣酒，唱着颂歌，欢笑着，回忆着，直到十月那个午后的太阳落下。
Oh, there were the usual pledges to stay in touch. Numbers were exchanged and casts were signed, but I think we knew in our hearts that this would be our last get together. Having become professional holiday writers, we were no longer friends but rivals. Wishing each other the best, while quietly hoping for the worse. I moved on with my new life.
哦，大家当然都承诺保持联系。交换了号码，在石膏上签了名，但我认为我们心里都很清楚，这将是我们最后一次聚会。成为了职业节日作家后，我们不再是朋友，而是竞争对手。表面上祝对方一切顺利，心里却默默盼着对方倒霉。我继续着我的新生活。
I spent a few weeks getting re-acquainted with myself, and then I took a job at one of the several petting mangers my town sets up each year during the holiday season. It was right after Thanksgiving. And I had a bit to drink. Maybe I was showing off. Maybe I was just a little too happy to be me. I drove my go-kart into the petting manger. And some of these animals, the camels and so forth, they spook a little too easy.
我花了几个星期的时间重新找回自我，然后我在镇上每年节日期间设立的几个动物喂养槽之一找到了一份工作。那是感恩节刚过的时候。我喝了点酒。也许我是在炫耀。也许我只是因为做自己而太高兴了。我把卡丁车开进了喂养槽。而这些动物中的一些，比如骆驼之类的，它们太容易受惊了。
The next thing I knew, it was two weeks later. And I was flat on my back in the hospital, waking from a coma.
等我再有意识的时候，已经是两周后了。我平躺在医院里，从昏迷中醒来。
Oh, doctor, the man in 26B just woke up from his coma.
哦，医生，26B病房的病人刚刚从昏迷中醒来了。
Oh, good. You can send him home now.
哦，好极了。你现在可以让他出院了。
I was discharged and returned to my house without walls, with a few scratches, a significant headache, and a prescription for a couple of salves they thought might heal a few of my bed sores. It was December, and I was in the drug store having my prescription filled. There was a stomach virus going around, and the pharmacist's line was 30, 40 people long. I was standing back near the magazine rack, thumbing through the current issue of Cotton Belt Lifestyles , when I read what sounded like a familiar voice.
我出院回到了那个四面漏风的家，带着几道擦伤，严重的头痛，还有一张处方，上面写着他们认为可以治愈我几处褥疮的药膏。那是十二月，我在药店配药。当时正流行肠胃病毒，药剂师的队伍排了30、40个人长。我站在杂志架旁，翻阅着最新一期的《棉花带生活方式》，这时我读到了听起来很熟悉的声音。
We'd gone to bed late that Christmas Eve. Taka, Soil, Prescott, and I lay huddled in our beds, rowdy as newborn lambs vying for a swollen teat. And while I have no recollection of the exact moment, sleep miraculously overcame us at some point during that long and restless night. The world spunt on it's frosty axis, and morning arrived. The brilliant sun trumpeting the arrival of this day when children celebrate the birth of a king.
那个平安夜我们睡得很晚。塔卡、索伊尔、普雷斯科特和我蜷缩在床上，像争抢母乳的新生羔羊一样吵闹。虽然我不记得具体的时间，但在那个漫长而不安的夜晚，睡眠奇迹般地战胜了我们。世界在它寒霜的轴心上旋转，清晨到来了。灿烂的太阳宣告着这个孩子们庆祝国王诞生的日子。
I started skimming ahead.
我开始跳读。
That was the year each child received a slingshot. Oh, it wasn't much, just a rubber band attached to a wishbone from one of old man Chesterton's tom turkeys. But oh how those bones were polished to a sheen. The rubber band attached with pride and precision. Now, I can catch us a squirrel for supper, said Prescott, the youngest. And we all laughed, as children are wont to do. It's a sound that haunts me still, stops me in my tracks on this cold winter day, as Prescott, so young and eager to please, would not live to see another Christmas. February is the coolest month.
那是每个孩子都收到弹弓的一年。哦，那算不上什么，只是绑在切斯特顿老头的一只火鸡叉骨上的橡皮筋。但那些骨头被擦得锃亮。橡皮筋被自豪而精确地绑上去。现在，我能抓只松鼠当晚饭了，最小的普雷斯科特说。我们都笑了，就像孩子们常做的那样。那声音至今仍萦绕在我心头，在这个寒冷的冬日让我驻足，因为普雷斯科特，如此年轻又渴望取悦他人，却没能活到下一个圣诞节。二月是一年中最冷的月份。
I picked up another magazine, then another, grabbing them randomly off the shelves.
我拿起另一本杂志，又一本，随机地从书架上抓取。
Basketball season had started early that year. And with my starting forward out with a torn meniscus, it didn't seem my Christmas was going to merry. I laced up my street shoes and stared out the window into the parking lot. We were expecting a minor dusting, but it was coming down hard, the flakes the size of those Styrofoam pellets they use to package trophies. Trophies, better put that thought out of your mind, baby, I said to myself.
那年的篮球赛季开始得很早。由于我的首发前锋半月板撕裂，看来我的圣诞节不会快乐了。我系好运动鞋，透过窗户盯着停车场。我们预料会有少量降雪，但雪下得很大，雪花大得像那些用来包装奖杯的泡沫颗粒。奖杯，最好把这种想法从脑子里赶走，宝贝，我对自己说。
It's three hours before the playoff. And I'm stuck in Manitoba, spoon feeding cranberry juice cocktail to my star point-guard Shanethra, who's got a stomach virus, and all the trimmings, and a fever of 102. The bus has moved on, and I'm there with Shanethra, who's flat on her back and her best friend Stephanie Twospears, who's sweating many, many rivers. I'm in a Holiday Inn, and the room is hot and smells of powder, modeling glue, and teak. There was a wreath on the door, and nothing good was on TV.
离季后赛还有三个小时。我被困在曼尼托巴省，给患了肠胃病毒的明星控球后卫沙内斯拉喂蔓越莓汁，还有所有的装饰物，她发着102度的高烧。大巴已经开走了，我留在那儿陪着平躺着的沙内斯拉，还有她那汗流浃背的好友斯蒂芬妮·双矛。我在一家假日酒店，房间里很热，闻起来有粉末、模型胶和柚木的味道。门上挂着花环，电视上也没什么好看的。
She wanted to shake it, not just the tree or the jagged ice daggers dripping from the roof, but the whole damn thing. She wanted to shake it like Stolly shook his mane of dark hair, the color of night, the color of ravens, of crows calling out in their hoarse whispers. Stolly shaking his head while playing the bass, that night before Christmas, silent night, the holy night. They spiked two grams of horse and ran wild, ran like the wind that brings up from a fire. She wanted to shake it.
她想摇晃它，不是摇晃那棵树或屋檐下滴下的参差不齐的冰锥，而是摇晃这整个该死的东西。她想摇晃它，就像斯托利摇晃他那头如夜色般乌黑、如乌鸦般深邃、如乌鸦在嘶哑耳语中呼唤的长发。斯托利在圣诞前夜弹着贝斯时摇头，平安夜，神圣的夜。他们给马注射了两克海洛因，像从火中升起的风一样狂奔。她想摇晃它。
The wreath swayed as the police pounded on the other side of the door. Go away and leave us in peace, my mother shouted. I don't know nothing about the disappearance of the O'Shaughnessy brothers. No one here does. No go away with ya. She motioned to me with her cane, and, I remember, she had a wee' bit o' tinsel on the slope of her shoulder.
当警察在门外敲门时，花环摇晃了一下。走开，让我们安静点，我母亲喊道。我不知道奥肖内西兄弟失踪的事。这里没人知道。快走吧。她用手杖向我示意，我记得，她的肩膀上还挂着一点点闪亮的箔条。
High-tail it out the back door and get word to Paddy McShane, she whispered. Go on now, go. Which I did. I sloped out the back way, and ran with all my might. I ran past O'Brians Pub and McNamara's Alehouse, past O'Malley's Tavern and Feeny's Roadhouse. I passed Father McGonegal coming out of the church, and I shouted, for the love of Christmas, who's seen Paddy McShane?
从后门溜走，去给帕迪·麦克沙恩送信，她低声说。快走，快。我照做了。我从后路溜走，用尽全力奔跑。我跑过奥布莱恩酒吧和麦克纳马拉啤酒屋，跑过奥马利酒馆和费尼路边餐馆。我经过从教堂出来的麦格内格尔神父身边，我喊道，看在圣诞节的份上，谁见到帕迪·麦克沙恩了？
It made me smile to think of my friends and that wonderful preseason Christmas we'd spent getting to know one another. It seemed they  had turned in their stories and had fulfilled their dreams. Me, I had never gotten around to writing my story, much less mailing it. My envelope had been blank.
想到我的朋友们以及我们在那个美妙的季前圣诞节里彼此了解，我露出了微笑。看来他们已经提交了故事并实现了他们的梦想。而我，从没写过故事，更没寄出。我的信封是空的。
I turned to the woman behind me and told he all about it. Then she turned to the person behind her, and so forth, and so on, until it made its way to the radio producer with stomach cramps and a deadline for his last-minute Christmas story. So I guess I did find my audience after all, didn't I. Good night all, and God bless.
我转过身，把这一切都告诉了身后那个女人。然后她转过身告诉她身后的人，以此类推，直到传到了那位患有胃痉挛、还要赶在圣诞节前夜完成故事的电台制作人耳中。所以我猜我最终还是找到了我的观众，不是吗。大家晚安，上帝保佑。
[SILENT NIGHT]
[平安夜]
Little music from the Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church from Chicago's South Side. We'll be hearing music from them throughout the hour, and we're going to have a visit with them at the end of the hour. Our play by David Sedaris and the Pine Tree Gang, exclusively here on Your Radio Playhouse radio program.
这是来自芝加哥南区信仰会幕浸信会教堂的音乐。我们将在整点节目中听到他们的音乐，节目结束时我们还将拜访他们。这是由大卫·塞达里斯和松树帮带来的剧目，仅在您的广播剧场广播节目中播出。
Coming up next, in our little cavalcade of Christmas stories, is a story from Beau O'Riley. Beau's a local playwright and musician, longtime member of the band Maestro Subgum and the Whole. And Christmas brings up such different feelings and memories for each person. His story is a story from his childhood living outside Chicago.
接下来，在我们的小型圣诞故事巡礼中，是一个来自博·奥莱利的故事。博是一位当地的剧作家和音乐家，也是乐队“大师苏布冈和全体成员”的长期成员。圣诞节为每个人带来了如此不同的感受和回忆。他的故事是他童年住在芝加哥郊外的故事。
I lost my entire thumbnail closing a classroom window.
我在关教室窗户时弄掉了整个大拇指指甲。
I'm just going to start that again. We're having a cuing problem here. You can see that we are spooked by the Ghost of Christmas Present here in this program so far. It's been such a nerve wracking thing getting the program on the air, with everybody going away for the holidays, and us wanting to make the show extra special with all sorts of extra special new pieces. So we're just going to move back. You see, we're just going to have Ghost of Christmas Past here. We just going to move back into past about a minute ago and try that again.
我要重新开始。我们在提示上出了点问题。你可以看出我们在这节目中被现在的圣诞幽灵吓到了。为了把节目播出，我们真是伤透了脑筋，大家都去过节了，而我们想用各种特别的新作品让节目格外精彩。所以我们要往回走。你看，我们这里只有过去的圣诞幽灵。我们只需回到一分钟前，再试一次。
Two weeks before Christmas in 1966, I lost my entire thumbnail closing a classroom window as part of the Sister Edwardine seventh graders helped the school close their windows program. I'd been assigned to close them all up every day. And they were huge, swinging, picture-window type windows that demanded a seventh graders brooding aggressiveness to shut them firmly.
1966年圣诞节前两周，我在协助爱德华丁修女七年级学生开展的学校关窗计划中，关教室窗户时弄掉了整个大拇指指甲。我每天都被指派去把它们都关上。那是一些巨大的、旋转的、落地窗式的窗户，需要七年级学生那种阴郁的攻击性才能紧紧地关上。
It was warm that day, unseasonable, and all the windows were wide open. And the other boy just let fly, really slamming it. I was dreaming out the window when the metal rim of it caught the top of my thumbnail, and the whole nail just sprang off. There was blood and nerve endings skit-scatting out of my thumb, hot pain.
那天天气很暖和，反常的暖和，所有的窗户都大开着。另一个男孩刚才用力一甩，猛地关上了窗户。我当时正对着窗外做白日梦，窗户的金属边缘钩住了我的大拇指指甲盖，整个指甲就这么弹飞了。血和神经末梢从我的拇指里溅了出来，那种滚烫的疼痛。
A week later, I was back on the playground, my thumb bound in a plastic splint. Wrapped in so much gauze that it, the thumb, looked like an upside down bowling pin. I was five nine and a half in 1966 and built like a garden hose that had been used so many times that it has lost all sense of its rubbery toughness, its definition, and hangs like a limp spiral. My body was like that, pale skin wrapped around awkward bones.
一周后，我回到操场上，拇指缠着塑料夹板。裹着厚厚的纱布，看起来像一个倒扣的保龄球瓶。1966年我五英尺九英寸半，身材像一根用了太久以至于失去了橡胶韧性和轮廓、像个松垮的螺旋一样悬挂着的软管。我的身体就是那样，苍白的皮肤包裹着笨拙的骨头。
And that body had reached its full man-height at the end of the six grade. It would never grow another inch. This growth spurt had prompted a new attention on the playground. Suddenly, I might be of some use. Basketball was no joke on the playgrounds of my midwestern-boy-1966-hood. Basketball was the most excellent, athletically rational of games and, suddenly, I was eligible because of a quirk of genetics but still eligible.
那具身体在六年级结束时就长到了成年后的最高身高。它再也不会长高一英寸了。这次生长突增引起了操场上的新关注。突然间，我可能有点用了。在我那1966年美国中西部男孩的社区操场上，篮球可不是开玩笑的。篮球是极其出色、竞技上合理的运动，而突然间，由于基因的偶然巧合，我有资格参加了。
Previously, my childhood had laid itself out as one continuous torture chamber of belly clenching, flush producing fear, when it came to anything like running, jumping, or slamming. And now here I was, under the basket, pounding my dribble with my left hand, the bowling pin thumb riding the ball, a stiff little Napoleon rolling into battle.
以前，我的童年一直是在跑步、跳跃或扣篮等运动时，那无休止的腹部紧绷、脸红耳赤的恐惧中度过的。而现在我站在篮下，左手拍着球，保龄球瓶一样的拇指搭在球上，像个僵硬的小拿破仑滚进战场。
John Crescent was six two. He was almost fifteen, old for our class, and the shadow of blue whiskers edged his face. He was on the other team. And I had never noticed him before, except once, when dreaming out of Sister Edwardine's classroom window. John Crescent leaving school early for some reason, stopping at the edge of the parking lot to light a cigarette while still on school property. It was a bold enough move that I noted him and noted it.
约翰·克雷森六英尺二英寸。他快十五岁了，在我们班算大的，蓝色的胡茬在他的脸上蔓延。他在另一支球队。我以前从没注意过他，除了有一次，在爱德华丁修女的教室窗外做白日梦时，看到约翰·克雷森因为某种原因提前放学，停在停车场边缘吸烟，当时还在学校范围内。这举动大胆到让我注意到了他。
And white trash is what I noted. Where I got that phrase, I don't know. My parents, in 1966, were careful Kennedy liberals. And white trash was way too denigrating a phrase for me to have heard at home. But the phrase hung way back in my cultural awareness, shadows of trailer parks, and country music, and Brylcreem, and Twinkies three meals a day. John Crescent had all this about him. He spoke with a heavy, Tennessee, sweet-slur to his vowels. His teeth were dark and mossy. And right now, he was coming straight at me under the basket, his eyes wide after the basketball that I was pounding.
而且我注意到的是“白人垃圾”。我不知道从哪听来的这个词。1966年，我的父母是谨慎的肯尼迪自由派。而“白人垃圾”这个词对于在家里听到来说太贬义了。但这个词悬在我文化意识的深处，关于拖车公园、乡村音乐、头油和一日三餐吃甜甜圈的阴影。约翰·克雷森身上就有这一切。他说话时带着浓重的田纳西口音，元音发音含糊。他的牙齿又黑又脏。现在，他正从篮下直冲我而来，双眼死死盯着我拍动的篮球。
I was an odd boy back then. And the meaner kids all called me odd-head. And, I think, in that moment, I was thinking about white trash culture. My odd head cocked at an angle as I considered all of white trash culture. Its angles. Did white trash families spend their Sundays like professional wrestlers, tearing up the living room? Did they chew tobacco before they reached puberty? I was thinking these thoughts and not at all protecting the basketball when John Crescent hit me with his whole body and the ball spurted away. And I hit the pavement.
那时候我是一个奇怪的男孩。刻薄的孩子们都叫我“怪头”。我想，在那一刻，我正在思考白人垃圾文化。当我在思考整个白人垃圾文化及其偏见时，我的怪头歪向一边。白人垃圾家庭的周日是不是像职业摔跤手一样，把客厅拆得乱七八糟？他们在青春期前就嚼烟草吗？我正想着这些，根本没有保护篮球，这时约翰·克雷森用他的全身撞了我，球喷了出去。我撞到了水泥地上。
Now, I have a tendency to go all odd-headed and get day-dreamy in the midst of violence. And this dreamy quality has gotten me through more than my share of playground fights. I float back up once I get knocked down. And I floated back up this time, in time to take a return pass and to have John Crescent slam me with this whole body a second time. But this time I didn't fall. I floated to a new spot on the court, and I held onto the ball.
现在，我有一种在暴力中变得“怪头怪脑”并开始做白日梦的倾向。这种梦幻般的特质让我度过了不少操场上的争斗。一旦被击倒，我会飘回来。这次我也飘了回来，刚好接住回传球，然后约翰·克雷森第二次用全身撞了我。但这次我没有倒下。我飘到了球场的另一个位置，并紧紧抱住了球。
And John Crescent, just caught in surprise, and shoved me halfway across the lot. But when I rose up, still dreaming, and fired a shot over John Crescent's head, making the basket, he stopped. And then John Crescent grabbed my thumb. He grabbed it hard. It still waved like an imp with a baton above my hand. And John Crescent grabbed that nailless thumb, and he squeezed it too. And the pain went up my spine, and I popped my eyes open. John Crescent cawed, and he squeezed again. And now, I didn't know John Crescent before this. I had never had a conversation with him. And here he was squeezing my poor nerve-exposed thumb, like it was the trigger and I was the gun.
而约翰·克雷森，被惊呆了，把我推过了半个场地。但当我重新站起来，依然在做梦，并从约翰·克雷森头顶投篮命中时，他停住了。然后约翰·克雷森抓住了我的拇指。他抓得很用力。它在我的手上方像个拿着指挥棒的小妖精一样摇摆。约翰·克雷森抓住了那只没指甲的拇指，还捏了它。疼痛顺着我的脊椎往上爬，我的眼睛猛地睁开了。约翰·克雷森尖叫了一声，又捏了一下。我在此之前并不认识他。我从来没和他交谈过。而他在这里捏着我可怜的、神经暴露的拇指，就像它是扳机，我是枪一样。
I hit him with my right hand. A clumsy punch that missed his chin and glanced his Adam's apple. John Crescent gulped and he stepped back. And I hit him again, this time, somewhere near the chest, with my left hand. The little Napoleon digit crying out with more pain that made my spine jump for revenge. I don't know how long I kept hitting him. Long enough for all the other playground boys to surround the two of us, to comment on my lack of boxing skills.
我用右手打了他。那一拳很笨拙，没打中他的下巴，却擦过了他的喉结。约翰·克雷森吞咽了一下，退后了一步。我又打了他一下，这次是用左手，打在他的胸口附近。那个小拿破仑手指发出更多的疼痛，让我的脊椎因为报复而跳动。我不知道我打了多久。久到操场上所有的男孩都围住了我们，评论我缺乏拳击技巧。
And even as I was hitting John Crescent, my odd-head cocked back for a better view of the scene. I was watching the other boys watching me. I'd grown up with most of them. I'd been beaten up by most of them. I'd been mocked and teased without remorse by most of them. They weren't my friends. I happened to have a growth spurt in time for basketball season. They didn't care about me. And yet their faces all hoped and wanted, needed me, to beat on John Crescent, white trash John Crescent, who was more of an outsider than odd-headed me.
即使在我打约翰·克雷森的时候，我的“怪头”也歪向一边，以便更好地观察现场。我看着其他的男孩看着我。我和他们中的大多数一起长大。我被他们中的大多数揍过。我被他们中的大多数毫不留情地嘲笑和捉弄过。他们不是我的朋友。我只是刚好在篮球赛季前经历了一次生长突增。他们并不关心我。然而他们的脸上都希望、渴望并需要我揍约翰·克雷森，那个比我这个怪头怪脑的人更像外来者的白人垃圾约翰·克雷森。
I hit him again anyway. And Jon Crescent was reluctant to hit me back. He kept pushing me away with this long basketball arms and not throwing any punches of his own. We were interrupted, finally, by Sister Edwardine. Her sharp caws of Stop it, stop it now!" broke the boys apart. I turned my head, so as to see her coming. She was short, full beaked in the nose, and bird-like. And I pictured her cawing above our heads, in my own odd head.
我还是又打了他一下。约翰·克雷森不愿回击。他一直用他那双篮球长臂把我推开，没有挥拳。我们最终被爱德华丁修女打断了。她尖厉的“停下，立刻停下！”让男孩们散开了。我转过头，看着她走过来。她个子很矮，鼻子像鹰嘴，活像只鸟。我在自己的怪头里想象着她在我们头顶尖叫。
And then John Crescent, who'd avoided hitting me back as long as everyone was watching, hit me as hard as he could. And I took the punch full in the face. It landed solidly on my left cheekbone. And I saw the Aurora Borealis, my head ringing like a fire drill. And as I landed on the pavement, I thought in my odd-headed way, of all the primitive, prehistoric men who went gaga in wonder at the first sight of the Northern Lights in a full sky. And then I hit the pavement, and I passed out.
然后约翰·克雷森，在众目睽睽之下一直避免回击我，却用尽全力给了我一拳。我脸上结结实实地挨了这一拳。它落在我的左颧骨上。我看到了极光，头里响起了像火警一样的声音。当我倒在水泥地上时，我用那怪头怪脑的方式想到了所有那些在天空第一次看到北极光时惊叹不已的原始人类。然后我重重地撞在水泥地上，昏了过去。
The weather finally went hard cold the night before Christmas Eve. The lake froze solid. And I woke up to the early quiet, intending to go out and pick up the family Christmas tree. Our family having long ago figured out that a Christmas tree bought on the last day meant a substantial savings. Why I went alone that year, I don't remember. Usually, I would have gone with my multitude of brothers and sisters. But I did go alone, crossing the frozen lake. It was very cold. The wind like a wraith sucked all the heat from my body, before I reached the lot where the almost perfect seven-foot, short-needled pine trees still could be found.
圣诞前夜，天气终于变得严寒。湖面彻底封冻。我在清晨的寂静中醒来，打算出去买家里的圣诞树。我们家很久以前就发现，在最后一天买圣诞树意味着能省下一大笔钱。为什么那年我独自一人，我记不清了。通常我会和我的兄弟姐妹们一起去。但我确实是一个人，穿过了冰封的湖面。天气非常冷。风像幽灵一样抽走了我身体里的热量，直到我到达那个仍能找到几乎完美的七英尺短针松树的摊位。
It was early still. And I had to knock and wake the trailer on the lot in order to buy the tree. The Christmas tree man may have been 40, but he looked 60, with three weeks of blue-black whiskers and a morning can of Budweiser. His eyes never looked at me as we negotiated the cost of the tree. But once we agreed, he yelled harshly to his still sleeping son to come out and trim the base of the tree to my specifications.
时间还很早。我必须敲门叫醒摊位上的拖车房里的人才能买树。卖圣诞树的人可能才40岁，但他看起来像60岁，留着三周没修剪的蓝黑色胡茬，早晨就喝着一罐百威啤酒。当我们商定树的价格时，他的眼睛从来没正眼瞧过我。但我们达成协议后，他严厉地冲着还在睡觉的儿子大喊，让他出来按照我的规格修剪树底。
I was odd-heading and daydreaming about the amount of perfection in a seven-foot, short-needled pine tree, when the son came out, flinching as he walked past the Christmas tree guy. My thumb jumped and ached. He was John Crescent. And John Crescent was the son of the Christmas tree guy. My tree of choice was frozen to the ground. For a couple of minutes, the two of us had to struggle to work it free. And once we had, we stood for a moment in the morning cold.
我当时正“怪头怪脑”地对七英尺短针松树的完美程度做着白日梦，这时他儿子出来了，走过卖树人身边时畏缩了一下。我的拇指一阵抽动和疼痛。他就是约翰·克雷森。约翰·克雷森是卖树人的儿子。我选中的那棵树冻在了地上。有几分钟，我们俩不得不费力地把它弄出来。一旦弄好，我们在早晨的寒冷中站了一会儿。
And I looked at John Crescent, full in the face. His left eye was swollen shut. His lip puffy and still traced with blood. And I had never hit him in the face. He had successfully kept me at a distance. And then I saw him in my own odd head. John Crescent, the Christmas tree guy's son, having to tell the Christmas tree guy about Sister Edwardine throwing him out of school after he'd knocked me out on the playground. And the Christmas tree guy, full of Budweiser, knocking John Crescent around some.
我看着约翰·克雷森的脸。他的左眼肿得闭上了。嘴唇红肿，还带着血迹。我从来没打过他的脸。他成功地让我保持了距离。然后我在自己的怪头里看到了他：约翰·克雷森，卖树人的儿子，不得不告诉他父亲，在他把我在操场上打昏后，爱德华丁修女是怎么把他开除出校的。而卖树人，喝得醉醺醺的，把约翰·克雷森揍了一顿。
If John Crescent knew who I was, he had given no sign, staring out of his one good eye like I was a car wreck and him the insurance adjuster. But as my head filled with pity for him and remorse over our recent playground battle, he reached out forcefully and grabbed my still-bandaged thumb in his fist. Merry Christmas, he cawed, and he squeezed it. Merry Christmas. I shivered all the way home.
如果约翰·克雷森知道我是谁，他一点没表现出来，他用那只唯一睁得开的眼睛盯着我，就像我是场车祸，而他是保险理赔员。但当我心中充满对他的同情以及对我们最近那场操场之战的懊悔时，他用力伸出手，紧紧抓住了我那缠着绷带的拇指。圣诞快乐，他嘶哑地说，并捏了捏。圣诞快乐。我一路发抖回到了家。
[SINGING WITH BAND]
[乐队伴奏演唱]
Music from Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church on Chicago's South Side, 82nd and Cornell. It's Your Radio Playhouse . I'm Ira Glass here in WBEZ. More of this very music as our program continues. And a visit to the church, and what they're celebrating this Christmas, later in our show.
这是来自芝加哥南区，第82街和康奈尔大道的信仰会幕浸信会教堂的音乐。这里是《您的广播剧场》。我是主持人艾拉·格拉斯，在WBEZ电台。随着节目的继续，会有更多这样的音乐。节目稍后，我们将拜访那座教堂，看看他们这个圣诞节在庆祝什么。
Just a couple weeks ago, one of the producers, Delores Wilber, and I went down to the Daniel J. Nellum Youth Services Incorporated. It's a place where teenage boys stay, mostly wards of the state, in fact, entirely wards of the state. And these are kids who can't be placed anywhere else, having trouble getting placed. They all live there. And there are writing classes there. And various arts classes.
就在几周前，制作人多洛雷斯·威尔伯和我去了丹尼尔·J·内勒姆青年服务公司。那是一个少年管教所，住着主要是受国家监护的青少年，实际上，全是受国家监护的。这些孩子没法安置在别处，安置起来有困难。他们都住在那儿。那里有写作课，还有各种艺术课。
The writing classes, right now, are led by a local poet named Quraysh Ali. And Delores Wilber and I went to see what the boys' writing was like, maybe have some of them read on the show. And, in future weeks, we hope to have some of them read on the show.
目前的写作课由一位名叫古莱什·阿里的当地诗人负责。多洛雷斯·威尔伯和我去看了看男孩们的写作水平如何，也许能让其中一些人在节目中朗读。在未来的几周里，我们希望邀请他们中的一些人来节目中朗读。
And one of these we were thinking about when we went down there is maybe they could write about Christmas. Maybe they'd have some experience to write about Christmas. And so when we were there and talking to them and seeing the writing, at one point we did a little writing exercise. And asked, in this writing exercise, for each of the boys to write something about Christmas. And this turned out to be a dreadful mistake. Because most of them had nothing pleasant to say about Christmas.
我们去的时候想到的其中一点是，也许他们可以写写圣诞节。也许他们有什么关于圣诞节的经历可以写。所以当我们去那里和他们交谈并看到他们的作品时，我们做了一个小小的写作练习。在这次练习中，我们要求每个男孩写点关于圣诞节的东西。结果发现这是一个糟糕的错误。因为他们大多数人对圣诞节没什么愉快的回忆。
We went through the usual things that one might ask, just to give people ideas for what you're going to write about, presents you'd gotten, things you'd want to give to somebody else, people you'd want to give something to, things you wanted to tell someone. And had them either write it as a little story or a letter to someone. This on was typical. I'm just going to read this very short essay. This person's said.
我们过了一遍通常会问的问题，只是为了给人们提供写作灵感：你收到的礼物、你想给别人的东西、你想给某人东西的人、你想告诉某人的话。并让他们要么写成小故事，要么写给某人一封信。这一篇很典型。我只读一下这篇很短的文章。这个人说。
The thing I most wanted for Christmas was nothing, because I have nothing. That's why I'm here. The person I like to give something to is no one. I've always wanted to tell you that. I didn't want nothing. And that's OK.
我圣诞节最想要的是什么都没有，因为我本来就一无所有。这就是我为什么在这里。我唯一想给东西的人是谁也没有。我一直想告诉你。我什么都不想要。这没关系。
Well Reginald Gibbons is writing about a lot of things right now. But one of them, at least, concerns boys in pretty bad situations. He's the author of Sweetbitter , his most recent novel and other works of poetry. He's the editor of Triquarterly Magazine . And for his most recent book, he is doing some research. He is hanging around a lot at the Juvenile Court Building here in Chicago. And so when we asked him if he wanted to write about Christmas, he decided to set his story there.
雷金纳德·吉本斯现在正在写很多东西。但至少其中之一涉及处于非常糟糕处境的男孩。他是他最近的小说《甜蜜苦涩》及其他诗歌作品的作者。他是《季刊杂志》的编辑。为了他最近的一本书，他正在做一些研究。他经常在芝加哥的少年法庭大楼里晃荡。所以当我们问他是否想写写圣诞节时，他决定把故事设定在那里。
A typical hearing or trial is like a brief, highly organized dance. The public defenders work from a table to one side of the small courtroom, the state's attorneys from another at the other side. The clerk calls the next case. Someone steps out of the closed doors to the waiting area and calls out the name of the minor respondent. The child is brought in. A long moment later, someone's approaching, judge, says an attorney, to placate the impatient man behind the bench. In come three women.
典型的听证会或审判就像一场简短、高度组织化的舞蹈。公设辩护人从狭小法庭一侧的桌子工作，州检察官在另一侧。书记员呼叫下一个案件。有人从关闭的门走到等候区，喊出未成年被告的名字。孩子被带进来。片刻之后，有人走近法官，说，律师，去安抚长椅后那个不耐烦的人。三名妇女走了进来。
The judge says, his mother here? Yes, judge, the public defender says, indicating one of the women. And who is with mother, the judge asks. Grandmother and aunt, says the attorney. The judge says, aunt, please sit at  the back of the courtroom. And the woman goes there without saying a word. The other two wait, also silent.
法官说，他母亲在这里吗？是的，法官，公设辩护人说，指了指其中一位妇女。和母亲一起来的是谁？法官问。祖母和阿姨，律师说。法官说，阿姨，请坐在法庭后面。那个女人一言不发地走到后面。另外两个也静静地等着。
Like the women who are here to stand with him, the child is black this time. Everyone else in this courtroom is white. Handcuffs have been removed from his wrists at the side door to the courtroom. And, as instructed by the uniformed officer who accompanies him, he stands at the center of the bench before the judge, his hands clasped behind his back and holding, in this case, a jacket, a tube of toothpaste, and a toothbrush.
和站在他身边的妇女一样，这个孩子这次是个黑人。法庭里的其他人都是白人。他在法庭侧门被解开了手铐。按照陪同他的穿制服警官的指示，他站在法官面前长椅的中央，双手扣在背后，手里拿着夹克、一支牙膏和一把牙刷。
This legal episode takes only three minutes. The state's attorney speaks. The judge speaks. The public defender speaks. The person of whom they are speaking is not asked to speak and does not speak. Although they have had time in their service to learn somewhat the language that he speaks, they do not speak a language that's intelligible to him.
这个法律插曲只用了三分钟。州检察官发言。法官发言。公设辩护人发言。他们谈论的对象没有被要求发言，也没有发言。尽管他们有时间在职期间学了一些他所说的语言，但他们说的语言对他来说并不通顺。
The public defender meets his client in a small, bare, interview room. The client is 14 years old, and has been held for two weeks, so far, on a very serious charge of violent crime. His hearing, which will take place in two more weeks, will determine whether he will be tried as a juvenile, in this building, and have some chance to straighten out and go free again eventually, or whether he'll be sent to the court at 26th street, to be tried as an adult.
公设辩护人在一间狭小、空荡的审讯室见了当事人。当事人14岁，因严重的暴力犯罪指控已被关押两周。他两周后进行的听证会将决定他是作为未成年人在本楼受审，还有机会改过自新并最终获释，还是会被送往26街的法庭，作为成年人受审。
The boy is short, thin, he does not look directly at the public defender, his attorney, who is explaining to him what happened in the courtroom in those three minutes of the judge's time. It was decided that something will be decided. But this explanation too, is in the language of the courts. It does not make sense to the child.
男孩个子不高，很瘦，他没有直视他的律师，律师正在向他解释那三分钟法官时间里发生了什么。决定是会做出某种决定。但这解释也使用的是法院的语言。这对孩子来说毫无意义。
So in response to the explanation, which is that he is going to be given psychological tests, and he needs to be completely honest with the doctor, and then there will be another session before the judge to determine where he will be tried, he says, how long am  I going to be in here?
所以对于他将被接受心理测试，他需要对医生完全诚实，然后还会再有一次法官前的庭审来决定他在哪里受审的解释，他回答说，我还要在这里待多久？
For his crime, if he is convicted as an adult, he will probably remain in prison for the rest of his life. His attorney says, that depends, but it's going to be a while. We have to convince the judge not to send you to 26th street, right? Right. You know how we do that? Oh, man. You know how we do that? You have to do two things. You have to not get written up for anything while you're here. And you have to do well in school upstairs. Are you doing well in school here?
对于他的罪行，如果作为成年人被定罪，他可能会在监狱里度过余生。他的律师说，那得看情况，但还需要一段时间。我们必须说服法官不要把你送到26街，对吧？对。你知道我们怎么做吗？哦，伙计。你知道我们怎么做吗？你必须做两件事。你在这里的时候不能因为任何事情被记过。你还得在楼上的学校表现良好。你在这里上学表现好吗？
The child is not doing well. And he has already been written up once. People get in his face, he says. He says, he has a temper. All he really wants to know is how long will he be in here.
孩子表现并不好。而且他已经被记过一次了。人们找我茬，他说。他说，他脾气不好。他真正想知道的是还要在这里待多久。
It could be a long time, his attorney says. How long? Am I going to get out for Christmas? No. No? He doesn't believe this man is an attorney. He says, he wants a good lawyer. He wants to pay $500 and have a good lawyer.
可能会是很长一段时间，他的律师说。多久？我圣诞节前能出去吗？不能。不能？他不相信这个人是律师。他说，他想要个好律师。他想付500美元请个好律师。
His sleeves are too long. His pants are too big. He shifts in his chair again and again. The small, windowless, brick walled room doesn't fit him either. Is it more important to you, the attorney says, to react when someone is on you, so they know you won't tolerate that, or to not spend the rest of your life in jail? If the judge hears you've got written up, he's going to think that you're not taking this seriously. And if that's what he thinks, then he'll decide you need to go to 26th street, right?
他的袖子太长了。裤子太大了。他在椅子上动来动去。那个没有窗户、砖墙砌成的小房间也不适合他。律师说，是反应当有人找你茬时让他们知道你不会忍气吞声更重要，还是余生不去监狱坐牢更重要？如果法官听说你被记过了，他会认为你没把这事当回事。如果他那么想，他就会决定把你送到26街，对吧？
The child looks at every corner of the room and not at his attorney. He fidgets violently in his chair and flings his arms to one side, then the other. His attorney says, someone gets in your face, you have to walk away from it, right? And in school, you need A's and B's, OK? So we can ask one of the teachers to come down to the courtroom and tell the judge that you shouldn't be tried at 26th street as an adult, right?
孩子看着房间的每一个角落，就是不看他的律师。他在椅子上烦躁不安，胳膊甩向一边，又甩向另一边。他的律师说，有人找你茬，你必须走开，对吧？在学校，你需要拿到A和B，好吗？这样我们才能请一位老师到法庭告诉法官你不应该在26街作为成年人受审，对吧？
The child is taken back into the part of the building that is behind locks. After he is gone, his attorney says of him, he isn't going to make it. What he has to do is more than any adult could be reasonably expected to be able to do. And he's only 14.
孩子被带回了大楼后面有锁的部分。他走后，律师评价他说，他没戏了。他必须做的事情，超过了任何一个成年人能合理做到的。而他才14岁。
The day proceeds, more trials, more hearings, the courthouse empties. The worlds, here and everywhere around here, go dark early at this time of year. After rush hour, whether at the known street corners where traffic goes steadily by slowly, or at the quiet corners, where nothing should be happening, the snow falling since late afternoon makes everything quiet. And the street is bright in that strange, nighttime, snow lit way, from the light of a few street lamps, home lights, headlights reflected up off the soft whiteness.
日子继续过着，更多的审判，更多的听证会，法院空了。在这每年的这个时候，这里以及周围的世界天黑得很早。晚高峰过后，无论是在交通缓慢平稳行驶的知名街角，还是不该发生什么的安静街角，从深夜开始飘落的雪花让一切都变得安静。从几盏街灯、住宅灯光、以及从柔软白雪上反射上来的车灯光中，街道在那种奇异的、深夜的雪色照耀下显得很明亮。
But inside the juvenile detention center, it's still noisy. People are getting in other people's faces, taunting the weak, threatening, messing with their heads. Outside the dirty unbreakable windows, the snow is falling in the night, falling freely, softly, steadily, slowly.
但在少年拘留中心内部，依然很吵。人们正在找别人的茬，嘲弄弱者，恐吓，折磨着他们的精神。在脏兮兮、无法拆卸的窗外，雪在夜里落下，自由地落下，静静地、稳定地、缓慢地。
[SINGING WITH BAND]
[乐队伴唱]
So we wanted a Christmas story for this week that really was more religiously based. And we wanted some Christmas music. And to get both, we decided to visit a church that had something very specific to celebrate this year, and a great choir with which to celebrate it. One of our production staff, Peter Clowney, went to Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church.
本周我们想要一个更具宗教色彩的圣诞故事，同时也想要一些圣诞音乐。为了两者兼得，我们决定去访问一家今年有特殊庆祝活动，并且拥有出色唱诗班的教堂。我们的制作人员之一，彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney），去了信仰帐幕浸信会教堂（Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church）。
The church meets in a smallish building on South Cornell, near 82nd and Stony Brook. It's in a middle class neighborhood, but there's some tougher areas nearby. By about 11 o'clock on Sunday morning maybe 50 people are occupying the warm second-floor sanctuary.
这座教堂位于南康奈尔大道（South Cornell）的一栋小建筑里，靠近第82街和斯托尼布鲁克（Stony Brook）。它处于一个中产阶级社区，但附近也有一些治安较差的地区。周日上午11点左右，大约50个人聚集在二楼温暖的礼拜堂里。
They sit in groups, talking about their lives with Christ this week, about other things. And some people are praying. By 11:30, about 100 people are gathered this way. And when the praise and worship starts, music dissolves these little groups into one congregation.
他们三五成群地坐着，谈论着本周与基督同行的生活以及其他琐事。有些人正在祈祷。到了11点半，大约有100人聚集在这里。当赞美和敬拜开始时，音乐将这些小团体融合成了一个统一的会众。
[SINGING]
[歌唱声]
Reverend Donald Sharp begins the service at noon. He tells people to greet each other in the pews, to meet their neighbors.
唐纳德·夏普（Donald Sharp）牧师于正午开始礼拜。他让人们在座位上互相问候，认识身边的邻居。
As a neighbor. If I want to be forgiven by God, I got to forgive you.
作为邻居。如果我想得到上帝的宽恕，我就必须宽恕你。
I'm struck by how people greet each other here. My father was a minister in Georgia. Our church was half black and half white, but we were all Presbyterian. And, in service, when we greeted each other, we use to do it nervously. We'd brush fingertips and mumble at each other. A lot of us avoided eye contact. Here at Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church, people clasp each other's hands. They look straight in each other's eyes. They say, neighbor. This is a church where no one sits alone.
这里人们互相问候的方式让我深受触动。我父亲曾是佐治亚州的一位牧师。我们的教堂有一半是黑人，一半是白人，但我们都是长老会教徒。在礼拜中，我们互相问候时总是很拘谨。我们会碰碰指尖，含糊地嘀咕几句。我们许多人避免目光接触。而在信仰帐幕浸信会教堂，人们紧紧握住对方的手。他们直视对方的眼睛。他们说，邻居。这是一个没有人会独自坐着的教堂。
Calvin Bridges is the choir director. He is an athletic looking man in his mid-30s. He's got this sculpted beard. On Wednesdays, at choir rehearsal, he is all motion. He runs from organ over to the choir. He sings parts for them. He's sweating in this orange t-shirt. But during Sunday service, in his grey suit, he stands behind the organ and directs the choir from there, with his singing and by punching up the beat on the organ.
卡尔文·布里奇斯（Calvin Bridges）是唱诗班指挥。他是一位30多岁、身材健硕的男士，留着修剪整齐的胡子。周三彩排时，他活力四射。他从管风琴跑到唱诗班那边，为他们唱分部。他穿着橙色T恤，汗流浃背。但在周日的礼拜中，他穿着灰色西装，站在管风琴后指挥，用歌声和敲击管风琴的节奏来引导唱诗班。
[SINGING]
[歌唱声]
And the choir this morning is about 20 people, maybe five teenage boys who don't seem to be into it, a few young women who are, a couple men over 30. but mostly it's women in their 30s and 40s. They seem really to get along. The closest I saw them come to disagreeing was after rehearsal Wednesday night. Traci Kiraten, one of choir members, told the group about the dance school that she's starting with her mom and sister. They're going to be teaching tap and jazz, maybe some aerobics, and there is also going to be martial arts. Choir director Bridges is an ordained minister, he's a very devout man. He puller her aside and told her, martial arts could be an instrument of Satan. They came to an understanding.
今天早上的唱诗班大约有20人，可能有五个看起来不太上心的十几岁男孩，几位投入的年轻女性，还有几个30多岁的男人，但大多是30到40岁的女性。她们相处得很好。我看到她们最接近意见不合的一次是周三晚上彩排后。唱诗班成员之一特蕾西·基拉滕（Traci Kiraten）告诉大家，她要和妈妈、妹妹开办一家舞蹈学校。她们打算教踢踏舞和爵士舞，可能还有健美操，此外还有武术。唱诗班指挥布里奇斯是一位授职牧师，他非常虔诚。他把她拉到一旁说，武术可能是撒旦的工具。最终他们达成了一致。
Martial arts does have a background with, I think, it's the Far East religions like Buddhism. I'm glad that he asked that question. But my response to him was that the teacher, I'm not the teacher, but the teacher that does teach the martial art classes, he has a Christian background. And he is a ordained minister.
武术确实有背景，我想是来自佛教等远东宗教。我很高兴他问了那个问题。但我的回答是，老师——我不是老师，但教武术课的老师——他有基督教背景。而且他是一位受封的牧师。
[SINGING]
[歌唱声]
At this church they don't make a big deal out of Christmas. There are no real decorations around. Maybe two Christmas songs in their entire morning service. And when I asked people about it, they told me, they celebrate Christ year round. So why should Christmas be any different.
在这个教堂，他们并不太看重圣诞节。周围没有真正的装饰。整个晨间礼拜可能只有两首圣诞歌曲。当我问起时，他们告诉我，他们一年四季都在庆祝基督，所以圣诞节有什么不同呢。
I give God praise whether it be Christmas, Easter. I just don't take one day out of the year to celebrate. I celebrate all the time. Hallelujah, because God is good. Yes he is. He's good. I'm getting excited.
无论是圣诞节还是复活节，我都赞美上帝。我不会只在一年中的某一天庆祝。我时刻都在庆祝。哈利路亚，因为上帝是美好的。没错，他是。他是美好的。我很兴奋。
That's Angela Cook, a member of the choir for 25 years. She's one of the soloists.
那是安吉拉·库克（Angela Cook），她加入唱诗班已经25年了。她是独唱歌手之一。
[ANGELA COOK SINGING WITH BAND AND CHOIR]
[安吉拉·库克与乐队及唱诗班合唱]
4:30, we're back at the church for the mortgage burn. First, everyone takes battery powered candles and marches around the building.
4点半，我们回到教堂参加“抵押贷款偿清仪式”。首先，每个人拿着电池驱动的蜡烛绕着建筑游行。
[SINGING ] We've come this far by faith. Leaning on the Lord. Trusting in his holy word.
[歌唱声] 我们凭信心走到今天。依靠主。信靠他神圣的道。
Reverend Sharp founded this church 31 years ago, with 12 people. Faith Tabernacle Baptist Church now has 500 members, too many for this building. And last year, Reverend Sharp made a decision. He told his congregation, look, we're going to pay $90,000 left on our mortgage. Not by the year 2004, like we're supposed to, but now. Because once we've done that, we can start building. We can build a place that can hold all of us.
夏普牧师在31年前创立了这座教堂，当时只有12个人。信仰帐幕浸信会教堂现在有500名成员，这栋建筑已经容纳不下了。去年，夏普牧师做了一个决定。他告诉会众，看，我们要付清剩余的9万美元贷款。不是像计划那样在2004年付清，而是现在。因为一旦做到这一点，我们就可以开始扩建。我们可以建造一个能容纳我们所有人的地方。
A year later, even Reverend Sharp is surprised that they did it.
一年后，连夏普牧师都对他们做到了这一点感到惊讶。
When we began last year to make a determination that we were going to engage in this campaign, I had to be very honest with you, I had some serious doubts. Not about God, but about you. Amen. I'm might as well, might as well be honest with you.
去年当我们开始决定要参与这个活动时，我必须诚实地说，我有一些严重的怀疑。不是怀疑上帝，而是怀疑你们。阿门。我最好还是对你们诚实一点。
As of last Sunday, Faith Tabernacle has raised $101,000. That's an incredible amount given how many people they are, and what people there make. It comes out to about $2,000 per person, on top of tithing, on top of the mission funds that they give.
截至上周日，信仰帐幕教堂已经筹集了101,000美元。考虑到他们的成员人数以及大家的收入，这是一笔惊人的数字。平均每人捐了约2000美元，这还不包括什一奉献和宣教基金。
And in a year's time, we didn't sell not one chicken, didn't sell not one banquet ticket, didn't sell anything. I could stand here and tell you the story as how we used to believe in selling dinners, banquets. And how folks would be mad at each other around here. Because you didn't buy no ticket from me, I ain't going to buy no ticket from you. All right. And how we used to have banquets and used to have ticket selling. And somehow the tickets and the money didn't come out right.
在这一年里，我们没有卖过一只鸡，没有卖过一张宴会票，什么都没卖。我可以在这里告诉你们我们过去是如何相信靠卖晚餐、办宴会筹款的。以及人们在那期间是如何因为“你没买我的票，我就不买你的票”而彼此生气。没错。我们过去常办宴会，常卖票。但不知何故，票款和账目总是对不上。
Anyone who's been part of a church, knows that no big moment in a church's life is going to pass without dozens of people speaking, and without a service that goes on perhaps a bit too long. By about 7:30 people are fidgeting. Teenagers in the back slump in the pews. But then, finally, the moment arrives. 20 or so leaders of the church gather at the pulpit, their backs to the congregation. They lay the mortgage in an alter that appears to be covered with tinfoil. It burns surprisingly quickly with a tiny wisp of smoke, while some people sing, burn, out loud.
任何在教堂待过的人都知道，教堂生活中的重大时刻总少不了几十个人发言，仪式也总是会拖得有点长。到了7点半左右，人们开始坐立不安。后排的青少年在长椅上瘫倒。但随后，时刻终于到来。约20名教会领袖聚集在讲坛前，背对着会众。他们将抵押贷款凭证放在一个看起来盖着锡纸的祭坛上。它烧得异常迅速，只留下一丝青烟，同时一些人高声唱着“燃烧”。
Christmas, in a certain sense, is about tomorrow. It's about hope. The child was is just born in the darkness of winter. He is bringing light with him. It's the perfect moment for a group of people who've stood with each other for 30 years to look to the future, to begin to build.
从某种意义上说，圣诞节是关于未来的。它是关于希望的。这个孩子出生在冬日的黑暗中。他带来了光明。对于一群相互扶持了30年的人来说，这是一个看向未来、开始建设的完美时刻。
[SINGING REPETION OF THANK YOU]
[重复唱着“谢谢你”]
Well, thank you this evening.
那么，今晚谢谢大家。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[资助名单]
Today's show was produced by Nancy Updike and myself, with Alix Spiegel, Peter Clowney, and Delores Wilber. Contributing editors Jack Hitt, Margie Rochlin and Paul Tough. We broadcast from WBEZ Chicago.
今天的节目由南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）和我本人制作，艾丽克斯·斯皮格尔（Alix Spiegel）、彼得·克劳尼（Peter Clowney）和多洛雷斯·威尔伯（Delores Wilber）参与制作。特约编辑：杰克·希特（Jack Hitt）、玛吉·罗克林（Margie Rochlin）和保罗·塔夫（Paul Tough）。我们从芝加哥WBEZ电台播出。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS]
[鸣谢]
The choir director, Calvin Bridges does have a record coming out, a CD, of the Chicago Praise Ensemble, some people from the church and some other people, from their recent tours in Paris and Scandinavia. Look for that.
唱诗班指挥卡尔文·布里奇斯确实要发行一张CD，收录了芝加哥赞美乐团（Chicago Praise Ensemble）的作品，成员包括来自教堂和近期巴黎及斯堪的纳维亚巡演的其他人员。敬请期待。
[ACKNOWLEDGEMENTS CONT.] I'm Ira Glass. See you next week.
[鸣谢续] 我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。下周见。
[SINGING]
[歌唱声]